[Music]
what does the scouter say about his
power level
[Music]
this scene is without question the
biggest mean to have ever come out of
Dragon Ball a show that has an
intergalactic allege Andheri prophecy
fusion through dense and Men that
literally screamed their eyebrows off
the most me worthy moment in Dragonball
history is a large buff man asking for
the reconfirmation of strength
statistics of a smaller less buff men
but did you know that this is actually a
mistranslation and that there are tons
of different interpretations of this
scene today I want to take a look at and
review four different versions of this
scene in order to figure out which is
the king of the memes in your eyes going
in order of release
I will first take a look at the original
manga chapter from 1989 the original
Japanese broadcast from the same year
followed by the English ocean dub from
1997 copy it all off with Dragon Ball Z
Kai's redub version from the year 2010
however before we dive into this I want
you to vote for your favorite right now
which do you think was the best click
the top right I asked this now because
at the end of the video I want you to
vote again it'll be the exact same poll
and I want to see if this video made you
change your mind or if it reinforced
your current pick and so with that
explained let's get this show rolling
with the very first time this legendary
scene hit the public eye and to do that
we need to go all the way back to the
streets of Japan in the late 1980s
Dragon Ball Chapter 224 was released on
march 19th via Weekly Shonen Jump in
1989 titled son Goku quiet anger this
was written and drawn entirely by Akira
Toriyama the chapter itself acts as the
original scene obvious events and is 14
pages long the events of this chapter
unfolds right after piccolo sacrifice in
defense of Gohan taking the full brunt
of Napa's attack before collapsing to
the floor and dying right as Gohan was
about to be crushed in a quick flash of
light he find himself at a safe distance
from the action sitting comfortably on
the Nimbus cloud
Goku has returned the cover of this
chapter sees an enraged Goku surrounded
by friends and allies that have
sacrificed their lives in order to buy
time for him to arrive the first thing
we see is a full-page spread of Goku
staring down nappa both relieved and
shocked to see him Krillin and Gohan
Greek Goku while Vegeta and nappa poke
taunt and tease Goku however doesn't
even acknowledge them walking right up
to Napa
he checks Piccolo's vitals he died
trying to save me
tension hood Yamcha don't tell me you're
shocked to find your lame friends are
dead come to think of it there was
another one blown to pieces
so chiaotzu - and commie his power is
increasing steadily hey what is it ready
to die already well here's my way of
saying hello in a flash Goku is no
longer in front of nappa but a decent
distance behind him guiding his son over
to Crillon lying beaten in the dirt
crouching down extending his head Goku
reveals the last sense of being split in
two Kron says that it would be a waste
of time for him to take it and that he
should save it for himself
however Goku concerned for his friend
says quit worrying if you're not going
to eat it I'm just gonna throw it away
Gohan and krillen accept the offer and
climb to their feet Goku does all of
this with his back turn to Napa and
Vegeta the former feeling incredibly
angered by this sign of disrespect
Krillin fills Goku in and all that has
transpired since his death explaining
how monstrous fighting just one of these
guys was and continues on by saying that
if three of them were to fight together
they should be able to take down one of
them before they all die but Goku has a
different plan for them to get far away
from here and to fight them alone there
will be no mercy for you you bastard
power 7000-8000 it can't be Vegeta
Louis kagura's power again over a
thousand eight thousand it's a mistake
it's broken don't worry I won't use the
kaio-ken on you yes kaio-ken that's for
me as quickly as nappa lunges forward
with an enormous strike goku immediately
counter-attacks faster than the fighter
can detect moving behind it and striking
the back of his head before he even
notices that he moves vegeta is shocked
as are crueler than Gohan but Natha
isn't happy and that's the end of this
chapter now that we have the original
scene under our belts let's see how the
animated versions compare starting with
the very first the original Japanese
broadcast original release November 29th
titled ferocity of the Saiyans Kamisama
and piccolo both died this episode
covers more than just one chapter of the
manga primarily it covers this chapter
however it also includes the end of the
previous and the start of the next and
one of the things that comes with many
anime adaptations is filling and this
episode has some not a lot but some
this is filler that serves no purpose
other than to pad the runtime there is
no conclusion to this gang at the Kama
House subplot and it never plays into
the greater story primarily because
Akira Toriyama didn't run it to be part
of the story however this is anime there
will always be some filler to be fair
and there isn't that much of it here
when we get back to the Canon part of
the story it's adapted quite faithfully
from a dialogue point of view and
visually for the most part one of the
detractors was that the anime provided
angles that weren't nearly as
interesting as what the manga provided
the anime seems to be a lot flatter in
many ways most likely for ease of
animation this might not matter to many
of you and might be a deal-breaker for
others
once the sense of beans have been
distributed to go on and krillen goku
turns to nappa and begins to power up a
beautiful pulsating aura animation is
present around Goku and as Vegeta
Scouter reads his power level
Natha inquires the episode continues
into the next chapter that sees much
more action and comparing it to the
manga there are some really really great
adaptations as some truly terrific cuts
of animation
[Music]
burning through much of the following
chapter in minutes as we watch Gohan
Crillon and Vegeta
in shock and awe as Goku styles on nappa
Masako Nozawa plays the role of Goku Ryo
horikawa voices Vegeta and shows Onizuka
lends his voice to the character of
nappa they all do a terrific job in
their roles but this might not be the
version of the scene you're all familiar
with next one however very well might be
the ocean dub original release April 19
1997 over seven years after its original
air date in Japan folks in the West
finally got an English dub of this scene
titled to the return of Goku as native
english-speakers the first thing you
might be surprised with regarding this
dub is its casting Brian Drummond plays
Vegeta Michael Dobson plays nappa and
Peter Columbus plays Goku God before
Funimation decided to take things into
their own hands in the late 1990s the
outsource to a dubbing studio in
Vancouver Canada called ocean studios
these were the original English voice
actors for the characters and just so
happened to be the original voice actors
present in the meme that spread across
the web and yes you might have noticed
at this point that this is a
mistranslation the two power readings
that are made in this episode 3000 and
over 9000 are both mistranslations
Gohan's power during this time is read
as 2800 and Goku's eventual power up is
to over 8,000 in addition to those
mistranslations dialect across the board
was altered to varying degrees
for instance and and face into another
dimensions
who should be back okay in the original
he was scolding him for not getting out
of danger when he was told to however
the ocean dub took every conceivable
course of action to make this action
Shonen as kid-friendly as possible for
english-speaking audiences resulting in
death scenes with awkward confusing
dialogue about dimensions and being
wished back I mean in this particular
scenario Piccolo's death has a direct
story consequence when piccolo dies that
Dragon Balls die too and he knows that
so narrative Lee it makes no sense for
him to say this at all in addition to
this decent
efforts were made to remove blood where
possible however all of that aside it
also gave us this it's over nine over
the following decades this particular
scene would become one of the most if
not the most popular Dragonball quote of
all time and to think it was a
mistranslation way that could be right
so with that it's time for Dragon Ball
Kai highly original release June 21st
2009 June 7th 2010 entitled tears shed
by piccolo son Goku furious
counter-attack the driving forces behind
the Dragon Ball Kai read above the
series was to essentially have a recut
streamlined version of the original run
of the Dragon Ball anime aiming to cut
up much of the filler portions to the
story where possible and they did
entirely the filler that was present in
the prior two adaptations were removed
which means no more fortune-teller bhava
scenes at kama house however due to the
streamlined nature of this particular
iteration instead of covering roughly
two chapters of the manga it adapts
almost for spanning from piccolo
sacrifice all the way up until right
before Vegeta enters the fight it's a
pretty dense episode in terms of content
the Japanese version of the scene is as
faithful as ever and so I will be
focusing here on the English the English
voice of Goku in this version is Shawn
symbol Vegeta is Christopher Sabbat and
nappa is Phil Parsons the Japanese cast
Saunders dawa and Hari , reprising their
roles of Goku and Vegeta with the role
of nappa being recast to Tetsu inada the
animation and overall presentation is
wonderful with the English voice actors
getting their chance to correct what was
widely known as a mistake among many
fans of the series it's over 8,000 stars
and so this is where things get really
interesting now that I have broken down
the original manga chapter from 1989 the
original Japanese broadcast from the
same year the Ocean Studios dubbed from
1997 and the Dragon Ball Kai versions of
the series from 2009 and 2010 I would
like to present you with the opportunity
to cast your vote for a second time
click here and let us know which
interpretation of the events outlined
you think presented at best did your
opinion change or did it stay the same
let me know in the comments down below
I'm really curious to see which meme you
thought was best if you want to see more
videos like this one subscribe
I upload every Thursday and don't forget
to leave a like or dislike on the video
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you all next week
[Music]
you